you know when I was doing a show called
deal or no deal
no soul patch a flavor you just had a
full yeah not a full I know I was going
through my head I was going that way can
you say full man shoe I'm a full Manchu
oh full man that's something you order
from a dwarf in Vegas Yes wow a full-man
shoe as Brad Williams it's a real thing
ask Brad Williams a full name well I
don't want that either way at the waxing
places because dealer no deal was so big
they would offer the Howie Mandel for
women we're getting waxed to get this
little this kid thing yeah they called a
landing stuff
it was a Howie Mandel you can get a
landing strip you can get you know a
Brazilian or you can have the Howie man
at the time
my son what's better than a star in the
Walk of Fame it is it is and my son was
dating at the time and can you imagine
like he got like scored he got away what
that'd make your own that's my dad yeah
nightmare